Movies are big business, and major studios
earmark their spots on the release schedule
years ahead of time.
As such, it isn't too early to start making
box office predictions for 2018.
There are dozens of promising projects slated
for release, so here are some of the movies
that are going to blow everyone away in 2018.
Han Solo
Now that Rogue One has proven that the Star
Wars galaxy is viable even without Jedi, the
Han Solo prequel, with Alden Ehrenreich taking
over the role from Harrison Ford, has sturdier
legs than R2D2.
The film, co-directed by Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller, co-stars TV's Emilia Clarke and Donald
Glover, and looks to shed light on how Han
became such a swaggering space scoundrel in
the first place.
Han Solo's faithful fans should be eager to
see a story from his younger days.
But the big question remains — will we finally
get to meet Chewy's family on the big screen?
(Wookie roars)
Hopefully, the answer's a resounding "no."
We'll find out on May 25, 2018.
Avengers: Infinity War
If we had to pick a shoe-in for smash of the
summer, it'd have to be Infinity War.
The MCU has really all been building up to
this moment.
Iron Man and his Avengers, the Guardians of
the Galaxy, Spider-Man, Doctor Strange, and
Captain Marvel — everyone's gonna be there
for the big battle's beginning.
This is the blockbuster of the year, no doubt
about it, and it launches on May 4, 2018.
The Predator
Kicking off a new round of interplanetary
big game hunting, The Predator finds writer-director
Shane Black — who was one of Arnold's fellow
soldiers in the 1987 original — making a
long-overdue return to the franchise.
Black's promised to make it "the biggest Predator
yet" on February 9, 2018, with the help of
sci-fi savvy stars Boyd Holbrook and Olivia
Munn.
Bad Boys for Life
By the time Bad Boys for Life hits theaters,
a full 15 years will have passed since Bad
Boys 2, when detectives Mike Lowrey, played
by Will Smith, and Marcus Burnett, played
by Martin Lawrence, decided that they were,
well...
"Bad boys for life."
It's a bromantic sentiment which is obviously
true if they've survived another decade and
a half together.
Little is known about what the duo will be
getting into this time, but if it's anything
like the first two films, it's bound to escalate
quickly.
"Now back up, put the gun down, and give me
a pack of Tropical Fruit Bubblicious."
"And some Skittles."
Pacific Rim: Uprising
The domestic receipts for 2013's Pacific Rim
were a bit of a disappointment, but the Guillermo
del Toro film was well-liked by those who
actually ventured out to see the stylish sci-fi
showcase.
Even though the lackluster North American
ticket sales of the first film seemed to put
the idea of a follow-up in the "unlikely"
column, international audiences, always ready
for a monster fight, gave producers enough
motivation to justify greenlighting a second
round of the Kaiju smackdown.
John Boyega joins the cast as the son of Idris
Elba's character from the first installment.
Expect a release on February 23, 2018.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
For many, Ant-Man was one of the most enjoyable
entries in the MCU to date.
The tiny title character, played by Paul Rudd,
was as earnest as they come, and the Honey
I Shrunk the Kids-esque visual spectacle of
the movie was just pure fun.
The final act set the stage for Hope van Dyne,
played by Evangeline Lilly, to finally suit
up alongside our hero.
So for those who've relished the Wasp's adventures
in the comics, it's about time we get to see
her fly.
And at least we know that Ant-Man survives
Infinity War, right?
We'll find out on July 6, 2018.
Wreck-It Ralph 2
Disney's Wreck-It Ralph was a commercial and
critical success that found a way to entertain
kids and parents nostalgic for the 8-bit era.
We know John C. Reilly and Sarah Silverman
will return to voice their unlikely heroic
duo, but all that's been revealed so far is
that it'll be released on March 9, 2018, and
Ralph will be "wreaking havoc on the web"
this time around.
And we already know that Reilly is an Internet
expert, so we're in good hands.
"In 1971, Bill Grates invented Michaelsoft.
Wouldn’t it be cool if I could remember
my DINGUS password for my email?
That would be cool!"
Black Panther
The Marvel Cinematic Universe is expanding
even further in Phase Three, with Ryan Coogler's
Black Panther branching out to Wakanda to
focus on Chadwick Boseman's T'Challa, who
made his debut in 2016's Captain America:
Civil War.
With an all-star cast that includes Oscar-winner
Lupita Nyong'o and Danai Gurira, along with
frequent Coogler collaborator Michael B. Jordan,
Black Panther is poised to continue the MCU's
streak of box office domination on February
16, 2018.
Aquaman
The brief introduction of Arthur "Aquaman"
Curry in Dawn of Justice was but a taste of
what's to come from Game of Thrones' Jason
Momoa as the trident-wielding hero, who'll
embrace his destiny as the heir to the kingdom
of Atlantis.
Director James Wan helms the wet and wild
action film, set for release on October 5,
2018, with Amber Heard, Patrick Wilson, and
Willem Dafoe also on deck to star.
Thankfully, there are no green stretch pants
in sight.
Tomb Raider
Even without Angelina Jolie back for another
round of archaeological badassery as Lara
Croft, the Tomb Raider reboot-slash-prequel
should fare nicely with recent Oscar winner
Alicia Vikander stepping into the lead role.
On March 16, 2018, the new film will take
viewers back in time into an earlier chapter
from the character's history...
"Well...kill her!"
"Hey!"
Okay, maybe not that early.
Croft will on a search for her father and
Walton Goggins is coming on to play the villain.
The Incredibles 2
Disney-Pixar's The Incredibles was a blast,
but writer-director Brad Bird took a long
break before getting down to work on a second
installment.
Details on the sequel are slim, but with our
live-action comic heroes mostly just fighting
with each other lately, it might be prime
time to offer up a return to good old-fashioned
villain-fighting.
If you're looking for a semi-sequel before
the film's release on June 15, 2018, you can
always dig out your GameCube and play Rise
of the Underminer.
Jurassic World Sequel
After what happened in 2015's Jurassic World,
it might be hard to envision a scenario that
would allow the world's deadliest theme park
to legally reopen for business.
But the film's box office domination made
a sequel a legal requirement.
While we can't even guess what they'll get
up to this time around, we know stars Chris
Pratt and Bryce Dallas Howard are expected
to reprise their roles on June 22, 2018.
That, and there'll be a lot of action figures.
"And a pteranodon battles a spitting dilophosaurus!
Each sold separately!"
Mission: Impossible 6
Tom Cruise's Ethan Hunt is at it again.
Director Christopher McQuarrie returns to
helm a sixth installment of the covert ops
action-adventure series.
While details are minimal as to what the actual
storyline will be, Cruise has promised that
some bonkers new stunts he's spent years training
for will be among the many set pieces.
Get ready for action on July 27, 2018.
A Wrinkle In Time
Amazingly, the cherished sci-fi-fantasy children's
classic has yet to be adapted to death by
Hollywood, and we're not counting the 2003
Disney Channel movie.
So for director Ava DuVernay, the sky itself
isn't even a limit as to what she can do with
this beloved tale.
She's brought in a boatload of A-listers to
help her bring the saga to the silver screen,
including Reese Witherspoon, Chris Pine, and
professional weirdo Zach Galifianakis.
Put some time aside on April 6, 2018.
The Flash
The DC Extended Universe gives Ezra Miller
his turn to shine here in a standalone turn
as Barry "The Flash" Allen, after the character
was introduced in Batman V Superman: Dawn
of Justice.
The small screen has been kind to the speedy
hero with The CW's The Flash, but maybe not
so kind to 1990's Flash…
...so there's really no way to know which
kind of Flash we'll get, especially now that
the creative team on the film has changed
multiple times, and the script has returned
for a complete rewrite.
Still, there's a good chance fans will race
to the ticket stand in 2018 for this one.
Jungle Book
Not to be confused with Disney's animated
1967 classic, or the 1994 live-action film,
or even Jon Favreau's live-action version
from 2016, or the slew of other adaptations
inspired by Rudyard Kipling's book about a
boy who's raised by jungle animals…
Andy Serkis' version of The Jungle Book, anticipated
for release on October 19, 2018, will feature
him in prime motion-capture form, alongside
sci-fi fantasy mainstays Benedict Cumberbatch,
Christian Bale, and Cate Blanchett.
Fantastic Beasts and Where To Find Them 2
J.K.
Rowling's Harry Potter spinoff series Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them is on deck for
its second installment, following Eddie Redmayne's
Newt Scamander and his pals on another leg
of his adventure through American Witchcraft
and Wizardry.
Following the first film's introduction of
Gellert Grindelwald, played by Johnny Depp,
and a mention of Albus Dumbledore, the second
film is expected to begin the battle for the
ages between the esteemed professor and his
former bestie-gone-rogue.
The film launches on November 16, 2018.
Mary Poppins Returns
Author P.L.
Travers might be rolling in her grave over
this one, but there's reason to believe the
new installment of the Mary Poppins story
could recapture some of the magic of the supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
nanny and her now-grown charges.
Emily Blunt stars in the title role, with
Emily Mortimer, Ben Whishaw, Colin Firth,
and Lin-Manuel Miranda supporting.
Dick Van Dyke is also expected to appear in
the film, but at over 90 years old, he won't
be climbing up any rooftops or cleaning chimneys
anytime soon.
Get ready for a spoonful of Poppins on Christmas,
2018.
Avatar 2
James Cameron has buzzed about a sequels to
his 2009 alien adventure Avatar for ages,
and after years of much hype and delay, it's
finally, probably, maybe actually happening.
Sam Worthington and Zoe Saldana are expected
to reprise their roles as the formerly interspecies
romantic partners Jake and Neytiri, and somehow
Sigourney Weaver is also going to be involved,
despite the death of her character.
But she's also hinted that the pic might just
get pushed back again beyond its expected
December 21, 2018 release date.
Maze Runner: The Death Cure
Production on the third Maze Runner installment
was significantly delayed back in April 2016
due to a gruesome injury suffered by lead
actor Dylan O'Brien on the set.
Despite that setback and a middling domestic
box office return on the first sequel, The
Scorch Trials, the series' third run at the
big screen should kick off on January 12,
2018 — nearly a year after its planned release
date.
But its promise to finally give those gladers
their big showdown with WCKD should be enough
to give audiences their second wind and get
them out for the franchise's finish line.
Ready Player One
While young adult dystopias haven't all done
well at the box office lately, Ernest Cline's
bestselling novel has all the components to
make it a solid success.
Combine an engrossing Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory-meets-Hackers narrative,
with a strong cast including Ben Mendelsohn,
T.J. Miller, and Olivia Cooke, and blockbuster
director Steven Spielberg, and you have a
recipe for success.
Start getting ready on March 30, 2018.
If it's anything like the book, it'll be an
amazing trip back to the '80s.
(whipping it good)
Rampage
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson just can't seem
to miss lately.
So with him on deck to star in this adaptation
of the classic arcade game about giant monsters
destroying city skylines for the heck of it,
it doesn't actually matter that it's a ridiculous
concept.
Johnson will reunite with director Brad Peyton
— the same pairing that brought box office
glory to 2012's Journey 2: The Mysterious
Island and 2015's San Andreas.
Get ready for giant apes and killer lizards
on April 20, 2018.
How The Grinch Stole Christmas
Apparently, we haven't seen the last of Dr.
Seuss' Christmas-stealing character.
While Jim Carrey's turn as the holiday-hating
beast was enough to satisfy the live-action
crowd, Universal Pictures is rebooting the
original on November 9, 2018, with Benedict
Cumberbatch lending his vocals to the title
role, because the first two movies on this
list starring Cumberbatch just weren't enough.
Ladies love the Cumberbatch.
"He was so close that had he been wearing
cologne, I think I would have been able to
tell.
Just the lightest Cumbermusk in the Boston
sunshine."
Deadpool 2
Ryan Reynolds made a triumphant return as
Wade "Merc with a Mouth" Wilson in Deadpool
after appearing as the mutilated character
in X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
The unexpected departure of director Tim Miller
is a little troubling, but Reynolds remains
dedicated to the franchise, and he's indicated
that the sequel might bring a mutant mercenary
named Domino on board for the next round of
action, as well as one more early reveal…
"The sequel?
We're gonna have Cable."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!